pues la monarquía y el rey juan carlos
en particular es una figura o un ente
que suscita bastante división en la
sociedad española hay que recordar que
el rey juan carlos fue una figura muy
importante en la transición democrática
española después la dictadura de
francisco franco y sobre todo en frenar
el intento de golpe de estado que hubo
en febrero de 1981 él al ser jefe de
estado y jefe de las fuerzas armadas fue
el que pudo frenar este intento de golpe
de estado militar pero en 2021 una
asociación una plataforma de medios
independientes hicieron una encuesta en
la que le preguntaban al pueblo español
qué modelo de estado querían un 39 por
ciento voto por la república y un 9 31%
por la monarquía eso sí hubo otro tercio
de la población que respondió que
estaban indecisos
una gran mayoría de la población
española si le gustaría que el rey juan
carlos
respondiera ante la justicia por estos
actos cometidos aunque hayan prescrito o
fueran
no fueran posibles de juzgar esta
inviolabilidad del rey por otro lado
dentro de la política el gobierno la
vertiente socialista del gobierno acepta
y atañe la la decisión de la casa real
de que vuelva el rey eso sí no permitió
que éste se fuera a dormir en el palacio
de la moncloa los brevemente los
partidos de derecha reciben con
bienvenida al rey y en la vertiente más
de izquierdas del gobierno del partido
podemos dice que el rey solo debería
volver para rendir cuentas ante la
justicia